Muy bien nos quedamos en el problema 44 nos dice
¿Cuál es la forma factorizada de 3a cuadrada - 24ab más 48b cuadrada?
Y nos dan 4 opciones, así que lo que vamos a hacer en este problema es simplemente
factorizarlo y ver con cuál coincide, de estas 4 opciones. Así que tenemos
3a cuadrada -24ab más 48b cuadrada ,
y lo que podemos observar aquí es que los coeficientes de estos 3 términos,
todos son divisibles entre 3, así que realmente podemos
factorizar primero un 3 de todo esto y entonces nos queda 3 que multiplica a "a" cuadrada -3,
por que me da 28 son 3 por 8,
nos queda ab más 3, por que me da 48, o bien 48 entre 3 simplemente son
16 y agregamos ese "b" cuadrada ¿Muy bien? Entonces estas 2 son igualdades y
ahora lo único que nos queda, es factorizar esta expresión, y esta expresión simplemente, si nos damos cuenta
en realidad tiene 2 variables digamos, la "a" y la "b".
Podríamos ahorita pensar por un momento que la "a" es como mi variable "x", que siempre utilizo para los
polinomios cuadráticos, así que
podemos pensar a  "a" como "x" y los números bueno, son
los son los que siempre satisfacen esta relación, de que tenemos que encontrar 2 números que sumados
me den -8b, de hecho
déjenme escribirlo de esa forma, vamos a tener 3 veces "a" cuadrada y aquí vamos a agrupar esto así,
-8b que multiplica,
vamos a ponerlo así -8b que multiplica a "a"
más 16b cuadrada, entonces si mí "a" es digamos el término que
equivale, digamos a la "x" que siempre he utilizado con polinomios, entonces me pregunto 2 números
que sumados me den -8b y que multiplicados me den 16b cuadrada,
entonces de esta primera parte, notemos que esto es positivo entonces
necesito 2 números negativos pero además, o bueno pueden ser 2 números negativos o dos números
positivos, pero la suma debe ser negativa, por lo tanto no puedo tener 2 números positivos, por que la suma de
positivos me quedaría positiva, así que aquí realmente lo que voy a necesitar
son 2 números negativos y ahora bien, esos números van a estar en términos de "b".
Tenemos que expresarlo en términos de "b" pero bueno, si omitimos tantito la "b",
podremos ver que si hay 2 números que sumados me den -8 y multiplicados 16 ¿Verdad? Por ejemplo
-4 y -4.
Sin embargo aquí debe aparecer una "b", entonces podemos poner -4b,
que si le sumamos -4 b nos dan -8b
y -4b por -4b, esto es -4b al cuadrado que justamente son nuestras 16b cuadrada ¿Muy bien?
Entonces en realidad, esto nos quedó en términos de "b" no debe confundirnos,
confundirnos más allá, simplemente la "a", la vemos digamos como nuestra variable "x" y lo que me queda
entonces es que esto es igual a 3 veces que multiplica la factorización de esto, y ya vimos que es "a" - 4b
por "a" - 4b y que esto coincide muy bien con nuestra opción C.
¿Muy bien? Vamos a hacer el siguiente ejercicio el 45.
¿Cuál es un factor de "x" cuadrada -11x más 24? Entonces déjenme
anotarlo nuevamente "x" cuadrada -11x más 24, y tenemos que factorizarlo. Ahora bien
también lo que podríamos hacer es,
bueno vamos, a vamos a factorizarlo ya después les comento un poquito al respecto entonces,
aquí nuevamente nos preguntamos 2 números que sumados me den -11 y que multiplicados me den 24.
Nuevamente éste es un número positivo, por lo tanto necesito tomar 2 números positivos
o 2 números negativos.
Ahora como la suma debe ser negativa pues no pueden ser ambos positivos, así que tienen que ser
negativos los dos y podemos pensar en los factores de 24 y rápidamente podemos encontrar que 8 por 3
son 24 entonces, voy a tomarme -8 y -3,
que al sumarlos nos da - 11 ¿Verdad? -8 más -3 es
-11 y - 8 por - 3 es
24, así que estos 2 me funcionan, por lo tanto esta expresión de aquí se factoriza como
"x" -8 que multiplica a "x"
-3 y ahora nos fijamos ¿Cuál de estos dos factores se encuentra aquí? Y bueno es el de la opción B y a
diferencia de lo que podría ser resolver la ecuación, esto no es resolver la ecuación,
aquí simplemente estamos factorizando,
expresándolo como un producto de 2
polinomios de primer grado ¿Sale? Entonces a diferencia de resolver la ecuación,
si resolvemos la ecuación nosotros estaríamos buscando aquellos "x" tales que esto fuera 0 ¿Verdad?
O que equivalentemente
esto fuera a 0 y por lo tanto, si un producto es 0 pues entonces alguno de estos 2 tiene que ser 0.
Si éste es 0 tenemos "x" -8 igual a 0 y por lo tanto "x" es igual a 8, o bien "x" es
igual a 3 pero, bueno ya me estoy yendo por la tangente, no es lo que nos pidieron, pero sólo hay que aclarar esa diferencia.
Así que vámonos con otro otro ejercicio. Vamos a ver
este ejercicio ¿Cuál de las siguientes expresiones
muestra a 9t cuadrada más 12t más 4 factorizado? Entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es factorizar
este polinomio de aquí, y esto es bastante interesante por que a diferencia del primer ejemplo,
aquí tenemos a 9
multiplicando a "t" cuadrada pero 9 no divide a ninguno de los otros 2,
entonces tenemos que ingeniar
ingeniarnos un poco como poder resolver este problema. Entonces va a ser un poco,
un reto a nuestra inteligencia.
Sin embargo lo que podemos notar y de una forma digamos de irnos
aproximando es, que veamos que aquí tenemos 3t cuadrada, que esto es un número al cuadrado ¿Verdad?
Esto es 3t por 3t,
entonces lo que podemos hacer es, digamos nosotros
proponer una factorización digamos que sea 3t más algún número que no he determinado aún, que
multiplica a 3t más otro número que aún no he determinado
¿Muy bien? Entonces lo que ahora necesito ver es si expresándolo de esta forma,
yo puedo encontrar algún valor de "a" y algún valor de "b"
de tal suerte que al multiplicarlos nos de justamente esto que tenemos aquí arriba, entonces vamos a
desarrollar esto y ver que deben cumplir "a" y "b", y entonces si desarrollamos tenemos 3t por t3 son
9t cuadrada de ahí,  que propusiera a 3t  ¿Verdad? Para que me diera esta expresión
y luego 3t por "b"
tenemos 3t por "b" sería más 3bt
luego "a" por 3t serían otros 3at
y luego "a" por "b simplemente es ab, que si esto lo agrupamos, estos 2 por que
tienen un término común, que es "t", esto es 9t cuadrada, también podemos factorizar un 3,
3 multiplica a "b" más "a" por "t"
más ab ¿Muy bien? Entonces fíjense muy bien, realmente lo que tenemos es que la suma de
estos dos números "a" y "b"
multiplicado por 3 me debe dar 12 y su producto debe ser 4, en pocas palabras lo que
necesitamos es que si 3 por este número me da 12,
quiere decir que esta suma debe ser 4 ¿Verdad? 4 por 3 son 12.
Entonces "a" más "b" debe ser 4 y al mismo tiempo "a" por "b" debe ser
4, entonces
necesito pensar 2 números que sumados me den 4 y multiplicados me den 4.
Así que lo primero que a mí se me ocurre es tomarme 2, 2 más 2 es 4, 2 por 2 perdón son 4,
entonces lo que tenemos es que esto se factoriza como 3t más 2
y 3t más 2 que en pocas palabras es 3t más 2 multiplicado por sí mismo 2 veces,
que es elevarlo al
cuadrado y eso corresponde muy bien con nuestra opción A. Digo también podía
pudimos haber
multiplicado todas estas opciones, eso es lo bueno de tener
las opciones múltiples, esta la tenemos que descartar por supuesto
por que no es factorización de nada y si desarrollamos estas 3 opciones pues tenemos que ver cuál
nos da esta expresión de aquí arriba.
Vámonos con otro ejemplo más.
Dice ¿Cuál es la factorización completa de 32 -8z  cuadrada?
Entonces lo que podemos hacer es, bueno si tomamos
32 - 8z cuadrada, podemos darnos cuenta que podemos factorizar
un 8 entonces, me queda 8 que multiplica a
32 entre 8 es 4,
¿Muy bien?
- z cuadrada ¿Muy bien? Entonces tenemos 8 que multiplica a menos,  perdón a 4 -z cuadrada ¿Muy bien?
Entonces
¿Cómo podemos expresar esto en realidad?
Lo que me invita esto a pensar es ¿Qué pasa si uno tiene en general
esta expresión? Digamos de la forma "a" cuadrada - b cuadrada y si nos damos cuenta
para cualesquiera 2 números "a" más "b"
por "a" - "b" te invito a que hagas este producto sería un muy buen ejercicio para que repases
producto de polinomios pero, si hacemos esto simplemente me queda
"a" cuadrada - "b" cuadrada. Entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es utilizar
esta expresión en esta de acá arriba por que aquí tengo una diferencia de números al cuadrado, en este caso
nuestra "a" vale 2 y nuestra "b" vale "z"
2  y "z"
¿Muy bien? Por que aquí 2 al cuadrado sería 4 y "z" al cuadrado pues es  "z" cuadrada ¡Muy bien!
Entonces si esto es cierto y te invito a que lo hagas tú como un ejercicio
simplemente me queda 8 que multiplica a 4 - "z" cuadrada que es 2 más "z"
según esta fórmulita por 2 -"z"
y esto nuevamente coincide muy bien con nuestra
expresión en "b".
Entonces espero te hayan servido estos ejercicios, de todas formas nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.